embarrassment to the cross embarrassed
state of Maine and to the party as a
whole how housings are conducted thing
[Music]
hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer for recent TV
I'm here on the convention floor where
the main delegates just made their last
stand to try to get their rampal
supporting delegates seated they were
unsuccessful and they walked out tell me
really quickly what happened in there
well we just got railroaded
unfortunately they do not want to
recognize our delegation chair there was
I properly put together amendment to the
credentials report that would have put
the people that were elected by the
people of Maine into their seats the
chair did not recognize the amendment I
mean it's it's horrendous what happened
to me the real duly elected delegates
are up here right there we had tons of
people screaming objection point of
order division all of these things have
to be acknowledged under the process
[Music]
they didn't hold a roll call vote and
it's tyranny you know I think that rules
have to be followed this is a time to
rally around the next president I think
it is a it was absolutely an
embarrassment to the integrity of the
process I've been stating all along that
the National Convention is not meant to
be a coronation it's meant to be where
delegates actually go use the rules of
procedure in the process to select
somebody I 22 votes
[Applause]
if you didn't follow the rules you don't
get seen it it's that simple this is
going to happen to other states you
think this is just the beginning the
central party of the RSC is going to
start silencing the voices of the
state's go state by state by state so
it's absolutely just the beginning you
think this will have a significant
impact for support of the Republican
Party by libertarian-leaning around
pulse this is a return to smoke filled
rooms the party's fracture this was
completely unnecessary and it's
ridiculous
you